all day here on channel 8 we're taking
you inside nellis air force base
alex there are nearly 12 thousand
military and more than 3 000 civilian
and contract workers over at the air
force base
a crucial part of what they do is at the
nevada test and training range
in a special report this morning orca
mana explains why it's so unique
so there isn't another place in the
continental united states
to be able to do what we can do here
it's known as the crown jewel of the
department of defense
a warfighters arena right here in the
las vegas valley
welcome to the nevada test and training
range and ttr commander colonel cameron
dadgar says it's the perfect place for
airmen at nellis air force base
and across the u.s air force to prepare
for battle that's because it's the size
of the state of maryland
and there's no air traffic above it what
that allows is
full use of that this airspace airmen do
everything here from flying in formation
to simulating missile and bomb drops
they are able to now
actually go out and do their techniques
their tactics their procedures
to the full extent against an adversary
that most best replicates what they
might
face in combat the nttr was first
established following the vietnam war
through studies known as the red baron
reports the u.s air force realized young
airmen
lacked training against realistic rivals
the first step was to create that
airspace and that ground infrastructure
to do that
one group of aircraft that truly
utilizes the nevada testing training
range
is the aggressor squadron that includes
planes like these which essentially
pretend to be our enemies
in the air we also have to be
experts in enemy hardware enemy tactics
aggressors are modified f-16s that
emulate the latest threats against the
united states
their capstone event is the red flag
exercise which is hosted at the nevada
testing training range
once complete airmen flying against the
aggressors are considered
ready for war red flag is where we throw
the whole
kitchen sink at them in other words the
entirety of the threat spectrum and
we're going to challenge them in every
single way shape or form that we
possibly can
but colonel dadgar says the nttr needs
improvements as her adversaries crank
up their capabilities they've become
more lethal the ranges have become
farther and farther out
it needs to be expanded to better be
able to
replicate what our adversaries can do
their ultimate goal is to keep us at the
forefront of the future fight
reporting from nellis air force base
orco mana 8 news now
and such cool video from the air there
the colonel adds over 80 percent of his
workforce
at the nttr are civilians from here in
las vegas and other towns around
the state coming up here at six o'clock
tonight orca will take a closer look at
the weapons school at nellis
as pilots train for potential threats
around the world john